let's talk about other crazy things that
happened in 77 so Summer of Sam yep 77.
remember that being a big deal do you
know what that is yeah
a lot of people yeah and he said that
his job he killed the tickle tickle he
killed then tickling was a really bad it
was a capital but they never found out
who it was yes just kidding yeah yeah
David Berkowitz no of course still in
prison and he heard voices yes
I got my serial killer because they
should have arrested the dog when you
think about it yeah
[Music]
all roads lead back to Nick always
um Studio 54 opens oh Studio 54 opens
Saturday Night Live is uh really hitting
its stride by 77 it's a huge thing the
uh New York City blackout
I mean there's a lot of a lot of stuff
Jimmy Carter takes office Elvis dies
horrible horrible oh and guess who dies
shortly after Elvis dies and no one pays
attention because the Elvis news is so
big Groucho Marx is that true yep I
remember being also a huge Marx Brothers
fan and shortly after uh Elvis dies
Groucho Marx passes away and it gets
kind of a
we'll take a brief moment from all this
Elvis coverage I don't know yeah that's
like some more faucet on the same day as
Michael Jackson yeah
and then Michael Jackson died like an
hour or two later and uh she really she
she got short Thrift I'm gonna have my
publicist do a lot of calling around
before I pass
under Brian's about to get
together this afternoon blog yeah he
wants the whole afternoon and into the
evening
how's uh how's Kimmel feeling
's fine he took care of himself oh how
about Colbert Uncle Bear he's okay he's
gonna hang in for at least another month
good all right well I'm out then and
then just as I'm gonna start to just go
up to see the light I'm going to start
my my soul is going to start to leave my
body and then a massive star is going to
be killed in a balloon yeah and I'm
gonna jump back into my body
that would that would stick around that
would be a feat I can do that you should
you should uh you should write a book
about that that's a great idea literally
as a as a novel the guy who's obsessed
with getting here
trying to figure out
it's really it's actually a really good
idea
but if it's a book as much if it's like
a 40 minute funny movie and it's
it's in uh is it Tom Sawyer or
Huckleberry Finn that sees his own
funeral I forget which one it is you're
the Mark Twain expert you tell me yeah
well I didn't get the prize Well you
deserve it but thank you so much you
didn't pass the quiz no I did Sandler
did uh uh I believe isn't it Huck Finn
who's up in a tree and watches his own
uh watches his own funeral
Tom Sawyer so Tom Sawyer yes Tom Sawyer
Tom Sawyer thank you so much for getting
that for us it is it's Tom Sawyer some
people think it's Huck Finn but it's not
but Tom Sawyer sees his own funeral yeah
but what if there were a guy who like
you wanted to see this I do want to see
my spectacular media coverage that you
get well here's the other problem we all
know that's not happening
it also is so so much of its timing I
can say it's somebody who covers these
things covers these things like so for
instance Tina Turner right she died in
like it was announced in an afternoon
right like like maybe like two o'clock
and it was like a really slow news day
and it got a ton of coverage but she was
also I mean
I'm telling you like some of it is just
timing like some of it has to do with
like how big is the other news going on
there so no this is on you you you need
to organize this oh no don't do that
yeah yeah it doesn't have to be the
death of him you don't have to
coordinate him when he dies but when
it's announced no bury it at a Friday at
5 p.m I know
the last thing I do for you and I'm
gonna botch it during the Oscars
so it's how you go I think if I can you
know like if I bought a Zeppelin
and I took it up you know what I mean
and collided with uh another Zeppelin
yeah and you know it's got to be
spectacular you can't die of natural
cause wait a minute attacked by a lion
while in a zeppelin flying thousands of
feet it could be like rescuing someone
like it like oh that's good yeah that's
good like you're heroic it's a heroic
death we didn't we didn't appreciate him
while he was here we didn't know we
didn't talk enough about his heroic side
hey how about this Jake you're in the
news business and I could uh I could
slip you a couple of bucks let's say
however I go and let's say it's even if
it's uh it you know just not it's it's
not great like a toilet yeah and I have
I just had lunches I just had very bad
diarrhea
and I died of diarrhea and it was just
three days of it and people die people
die of diarrhea
it's not one it's not one bout of
diarrhea it's like days and days
it's just an explosion it's one long
explosion and so my point is that's how
I go
I'm gonna have Sona contact you Jake and
you're gonna say try to foil a robbery
to protect oh you know you've gotta
you've got a Sona says like in a bizarre
diarrhea accident yeah I gotta take
pictures of it and I post them up
everywhere I'm not the one to trust with
this yeah speaking which can I say
something about Elvis like so I learned
while writing this book that one of the
reasons why some people blamed uh Rupert
Murdoch for the death of Elvis Presley
and I'll tell you why because he had a
couple uh bodyguards that his dad Vernon
fired and then they well Elvis is okay
yeah and they didn't they did a tell-all
yes Elvis's uh two of Elvis's bodyguards
one was uh Red West right and the other
I can't remember which one it was uh
blue East no it's in the back
blue East what I have uh I've
contributing anything yeah look you're
reading through your own book now well I
have as you know I do who did they ever
cut back to you on CNN and you forgot
and you're reading your own book it's no
that's the way to get cover up Red West
yes Sunny West and Dave hebler okay as
told to Steve Dunleavy right who worked
for the New York Post who worked for
Murdoch and that so they sold this book
and this book came out and some people
think it's so depressed Elvis by the
book was called Elvis what happened and
it was his two bodyguards saying man is
he in rough shape Elvis and maybe people
think that that was that was one of the
precipitating events that caused him to
like overdose and that's how he died and
so there are people out there who blame
Rupert Murdock for the death of Elvis
Presley I mean because because he
published the book Steve Dunleavy and it
might be other things to get mad at
Rupert Murdoch about before that's I'm
not saying I'm one of and also like they
were telling and their story about Elvis
was true I mean what they were saying
about him was accurate right nobody
disputes that but anyway how did you
know about Red West and sunny West
other than by reading my book
oh I know all kinds I just I think I
think I know a lot about it he's an
Elvis fanatic well a fanatic is a little
crazy yeah I know a lot about it you're
a big fan of him when I know when I when
I have areas of Interest I go deep and
then I know a lot about it and so that
would include but I think that that
spreads over a wide area there are many
areas of Interest whether it's Elvis
Presley Elvis Costello uh Lou Costello
of Abbott and Costello those are my
three areas of Interest
foreign